[Musique]
le bruit de la guerre est constant à
barmouth
à tel point que les rares passants ne
réagissent même plus au détonation des
opus
ça y vient ici chaque jour avec des eaux
pour les chiens errants
le dernier kiosque à café encore ouvert
dans le centre ville
en deux
la plupart des combats ont lieu sur la
rive Est
de l'autre côté de ce pont détruit se
trouve la partie Est de la ville de
backmouth maintenant l'appel la zone
grise et d'ici on peut entendre les
combats qui opposent l'armée ukrainienne
qui tient cette position et l'armée
russe qui pousse sur les faux bourgs
tuent les carreaux souffler d'autres
sont en ruine les derniers habitants de
la ville doivent subsister sans
électricité sans gaz sans au courant
sans chauffage et sans réseau pour s'en
sortir nombre d'entre eux viennent ici
ce centre humanitaire offre de la
nourriture des boissons chaudes du
courant et parfois même du wifi
l'occasion de se réchauffer et de se
retrouver
c'est toujours comme aujourd'hui bondé
il y avait moins de monde quand le sol
était verglacé
mais nous devons nous occuper des
personnes âgées la moitié d'entre elles
sont seules elles ont besoin d'aide nous
savons de quoi elles ont besoin si ce
n'est pas nous qui le fera donc
plus de 90% de la population de barmut à
fuy l'épuisement de moins de violence se
lit sur le visage de ceux qui ont choisi
où ont été forcés de rester